plastique papier carton métal ouvert
plusieurs contenants et emballages
prennent depuis près de 30 ans le chemin
des centres de tri dans cette jungle de
matières diverses
savons-nous vraiment ce qui se recycle
[Musique]
le plusieurs centres de tri qui
desservent municipalité donc selon
qu'elles sont de très bonnes matières
les matières acceptées sont pas tout à
fait les mêmes sur des bases par contre
est-ce que c'est un combat est que sur
l'emballage ou à l'imprimé si on répond
non à une ou l'autre des questions un
grand doute parce que ça va aller dans
le vague drunk love les papier ou carton
sont les matières facilement
identifiables par papier en venant
papier imprimé circulaire un papier
journal
tout ce papier leur facilement on met
dans le bac de récupération
ensuite tous les contenants de verre
sont récupérables et des technologies
qui se développe pour recycler le verre
pont en refaisant des bouteilles de
verre mais en le réintégrant dando
procédé dans du béton dans faire ça dans
du pays de verre dans les meubles au
stylet avec d'autres matières donc on a
tous fait quand même une autre vie aux
verts qui est en train de se développer
les emplois
du côté des métaux c'est simple tout
contenant se recycle les conserve les
canettes en aluminium consignés ou pas
puis les assiettes ou même le papier
d'aluminium qu'on essaie de regrouper le
plus possible du coc des plastiques il
faut se fier aux numéros dans le ruban
de mobius sur l'emballage de 1 à 5 et le
7 pas de problème ça se recycle ce sont
les bouteilles d'eau par exemple où les
contenants de savon à vaisselle ou à
lessive le plastique numéro 6 toutes les
barquettes en styromousse août ou le
polystyrène ne sont pas encore traitées
à grande échelle dans les centres de
recyclage
j'ai lu plusieurs technologies et
plusieurs entreprises qui veulent aller
vers ça pour pouvoir reprendre la
matière et la reuss cris mais c'est long
à développer on recycle uniquement 18%
du polystyrène ou québec loin derrière
l'ontario et la colombie-britannique qui
le récupère à près de 95% et la nouvelle
écosse pas 100%
si certaines matières recyclables sont
somme toute assez évidente à reconnaître
d'autres laisse perplexe ou que du
papier même si un peu de place et que
moi si on me fait un bac de récupération
celle ci c'est vraiment juste deux
papiers aucun problème où on peut se
poser plus de questions c'est dans ces
gens de nouveaux emballages en plastique
là cela ils vont pas au recyclage donc
lui on va le mettre à la poubelle la
même chose pour lui qui a une portion en
plastique une portion en aluminium
plusieurs matières ensemble ils vont à
la poubelle dans les cartons mais c'est
simple les cartons ce qu'il faut faire
attention c'est justement de boîtes de
biscuits pour retirer si jamais soit que
le petit plateau biscuits ou déployant
un sac au stick ou le retirer pour
s'assurer que le carton est recyclé et
s'assurer que la barquette à la halle
aux bons numéros 6 numéro un on est
aussi au restylage tetra pak recyclage
tout ensemble comme ça si on osait
plusieurs matières oui c'est cela le
problème dans celui ci sait que
plusieurs matières j'irai à la limite
le bouchon est recyclable parce qu'il ya
même un numéro déçu
l'aluminium on pourrait le mettre au
recyclage mais le reste de la bouteille
va aller à la poubelle
parmi les sacs de plastique
on en retrouve de toutes sortes et on se
demande souvent quoi faire avec un truc
simple si ça s'étire on recycle sinon on
gêne
malheureusement vos sacs de céréales bio
de croustilles ou de nourriture pour
animaux en plastique à la poubelle les
sacs ou bellick hull qui s'étire on en
fait un sac de 5
[Musique]
pourquoi les sacs dans les sacs centre
de tri ça va vite se déchaîne sur les
convoyeurs si on laisse nos sacs libre
ils vont juste prendre dans les
différents convoyeur ils ne se
retrouveront pas recyclés en faisant un
sac de sac
il va vraiment suivre la chaîne il
pourrait être retiré et faire un ballon
le ce a rappelé que l'on peut tout
mettre
mais si la collecte sélective vous
semble contraignante les résultats sont
concluants
le taux de récupération dépasse
maintenant les 60 % de matières
recyclables